[Music]
[Music]
hey everybody happy sunday how's it
going
yep we are gonna do chang shi
this is a marvel movie you guys know i'm
not a big fan of marvel movies um
but we saw this one at the adobe theater
and uh at amc
and uh
it was pretty good i actually enjoyed
this one probably more than
i guess because it was sort of like even
though it was tied in with the other
marvel movies like it you know it refers
kind of back to the mandarin from iron
man and stuff like that and there's like
some recurring characters but it's kind
of its own thing yeah so you can it
refers back but you don't need to know
it right that's what i mean so that's
what i liked about it it's like you
don't have to like bring this big like
notebook full of
full of notes and references i mean
obviously if you have that and like you
know all the lore
then um you'll appreciate it a lot more
like all the stuff turning up but
i liked it because it was like a
standalone type story even though it was
kind of sort of linked in with the other
stuff yeah and it um
it's kind of interesting it's
it's it's like the ultimate 80s kung fu
action flick
in a way almost kind of like
big trouble in a little china in a way
just not that saney it is kind of
[ __ ] zany at times
but
in the marvel kind of way i mean yeah
it's funny it's it's cool because it
seems like it's otherworldly the yeah it
seems like the best combo of like the
marvel formula but also
you know
80s action kung fu movies with like kind
of like a
mystical type of element which i thought
was like kind of a cool combination and
i think they pulled it off pretty well
yeah the story takes place in a couple
in different time zones
like what your ancestors were doing like
what your mom and how your mom and dad
meant
actually not how your mom and dad meant
to talk about it
cheese origin story has to do with his
mom and dad so it shows them how they
met they like met back in the damn
crouching tiger hidden dragon [ __ ]
times back in the medieval period like
they don't age all right they got a hold
of some [ __ ] magic powers and they
can lose the 10 rings you know yeah
make or making him illegal illegal
immortal
so
you know started back in the day you
know back in the crouching tiger days
and then it ends up in macau and it ends
up in down
the united states of china it's actually
it was chinatown and and and then it
ends up
in another dimension yeah the first
part's in san francisco yeah
so i think a lot of people were
expecting this to kind of cross over
with ant-man because the ant-man stuff
is also set in san francisco but they
didn't really do that well earlier some
of it takes place in the special chinese
dimension that's where all those dragons
are tallow that's the name that's what
they call it but we know what it really
is
it's really the special chinese
dimension that's where all the ch most
chinese and chinese stuff exists
flying chinese dragons that was pretty
cool like chinese lions they're they
look that was also pretty cool shiny
horses that then they look exactly like
they were drawn with in in chinese
traditional art they got human eyes and
[ __ ]
beards you know i was a big fan i have
to say i mean the production design on
this is gorgeous um i was a big fan of
all the dragon scale armor and weapons i
thought those looked pretty awesome so
some of the warfare has to take place in
this other dimension it's where those
rings came from
and then there's all kinds of stuff you
know evil soul sucking dragons
um
evil
tentacle [ __ ] flying soul suckers uh
yeah i guess were those like the baby
soul suckers i guess they were like or
the minions i guess yeah the minions of
evil spirits evil chinese spirits
uh so the whole chinese
traditional motif and modern chinese
motif is in the movie and i liked how
they did it it was pretty good the story
so wearing storytelling was awesome
or uh it was solid
um
kind of star warsy you know
father-son tensions between good and
evil um
yeah it's like a family drama kind of
too because it's like you know it's kind
of him fighting against his dad who's
sort of marginally a bad guy but
he's also interesting because he's
straight up a villain but he also has
motivations behind and you also kind of
feel some sympathy for him so i think
like he's a really good uh villain and
like i said
the guy that plays uh
shang chi
is
he's like i think he was like the
perfect guy to get for this because do
you know that they've been like stan lee
wanted to make um a shang chi movie
going back to like the 90s when brandon
lee was still alive because he wanted
brandon lee to be in it that'd be good
um yeah but it's like it took so long
like they started working on this back
in [ __ ] 2001 right that's how long
this like [ __ ] took to make but i
love the guy that they um got to be in
it because it's like
he's just a really good you can buy him
as like a kick-ass like a badass fighter
guy and you can also buy him as like a
nice like regular dude yeah he's kind of
like the chinese uh superman in a way
uh yeah he comes across as very very
likable and very relatable he's got the
clark kent version of himself and then
the superman version sean sean yeah he's
got two identities he's got a sister
that he grew up with who's also
got these uh special chinese powers
they're just oh and i will say that we
saw the one credit sequence yeah um but
we didn't see the one at the very end so
there was one but i know what happens in
it so there's they're setting something
up for like the next thing as they
always do because they did have like a
mid-credit sequence and then i was kind
of like are they going to have one at
the end and everyone was leaving so i
was just kind of like maybe not because
you'd think that they'd be nerds and
they would know yeah so i was like so i
guess i guess they don't but i guess
they did because i went back and like
saw somebody talking about it so you
want to save to stay to the very very
end um
but yeah he's uh chang she's also got a
sister okay who they kind of grow it
grew up in the same training program so
she's in it also
she's like a side hero she does it a
bunch of cool [ __ ] too
and um she's cute guy cute outfit and
everything chinese outfit
um
they had
their early instructors are still in the
movies that was a pretty cool outfit he
looked kind of that weird kabuki mask
looking thing oh yeah yeah i'm
remembering that ninja guy the guy that
kept hitting them with sticks when they
were screwing up when they were kids
shangshi's dad's you know kind of like
this immortal warlord he's got his own
training school and [ __ ] all these
other badasses and mercenaries yeah he's
like a worldwide criminal mastermind
like i said they brought his character
up way the hell back in the first iron
man movie
so i gotta say um i had very little
expectations for the movie i really
don't give a [ __ ] about the marvel
universe which i think that makes me a
good judge of this movie because i'm not
invested i'm just going to tell you what
it was like as a movie
i know nothing about the shang chi
character in the comic books or anything
so i'm very neutral and impartial to it
i didn't have high or low ex i had low
expectations actually but i had no
preconceived
expectations i just judged the movie on
based on what i saw and what my
experience was in the theater these
movies are kind of real
uh [ __ ] there's a lot of controversy
about these movies because you know you
got fanboys that [ __ ] like it or
don't like it because it didn't match
with this or that or then they're
worried about well how woke is it is it
too woke or not woken up like i don't
give a [ __ ] i didn't really see them so
much
sometimes heavy-handed [ __ ] [ __ ]
i don't like it either i didn't notice
anything about it that
leaned one way or the other it was just
a normal movie
uh if there was i hadn't seen any did
you see any [ __ ] wokeness per se i
think that's a stupid concept but i
didn't see it just seemed like a normal
movie like most movies seem like normal
movies but you know you have to see guys
on youtube saying oh this movie this and
that but they'll complain about it well
they say that because every [ __ ]
because everybody clicks on it because
they're controversial yeah yeah they say
that about every single year they're
gonna make the men look like [ __ ] and
make them women all look like
superheroes to me they just look like a
normal movie the mid the uh shang chi
was a normal male hero they would you
know it wasn't emasculated or anything i
did it it didn't it didn't seem to have
any you know yeah it had a chinese motif
but that's in the spirit of this
character and the world that it comes
from that you've got to have that it's
like saying well it's aquaman we can't
be underneath the water
let's make an aquaman maybe entirely off
yeah it can't be underneath the water
because too many people don't not gonna
lie i'd probably watch that yeah they'd
be like
some people don't curiosity
got a lot of people afraid to get in the
pool so we can't have aquaman swimming
around like that you know so they see it
like that just judge it as a movie
kind of i would say speaking of aquaman
i enjoyed this one as much as i enjoyed
that aquaman
i think i liked aquaman but i think i
like this one slightly better might be a
little bit better um the the only
complaint i have is it's a little bit
too long but i say that about every
marvel movie because but honestly it
didn't really bother me all that much i
will say that despite the um the
production design at the end like once
they go to tallow and once there's like
the big battle scenes with the dragons
that's kick ass
but i think the first half was better
when they were still like in san
francisco before they went to the other
dimension because this had legit
two of the best action fight scenes in
any marvel movie um the scene on the bus
yeah and the scene on the side of the
building on that whole time i was just
like this with anxiety like the whole
[ __ ] time like when they were in
macau and they're all like fighting on
the side of the of the building like
with all the scaffolding and [ __ ] holy
crap and that scene on the that whole
like extended fight on the bendy bus
that was amazing the fight on the betty
bust kind of reminded me of the damn
james bond fight where he's running down
the train and the train in the crane on
the train remember that kind of reminds
me i think the reason it was good it's
the reason it was good is because unlike
a lot of the battles in marvel movies
it's not like superpowers like everybody
throwing light balls at each other type
of thing it was an actual fig physical
kung fu
fighting and i just i liked that but
depending on what universe they were in
yeah remember that in this when they
were in this universe it did look more
grounded when they were in the [ __ ]
special universe of china of chinese
mystical universe they were flying
around holding onto backs of dragons
they were fighting so it kind of had
both both which i thought was kind of
cool and you know how they were kind of
flying a little bit during during the
yeah like crouching
because you're in another damn dress in
another dimension so it was in some ways
a little more believable i think to me
um
he could punch them rings off and grab
[ __ ] and pull things out of dragging the
dragon dragons are trying to soul suck
each other and that was pretty good
because it was almost kind of like a
godzilla movie gigantic dragons yeah
this kind of had something for everybody
like big ass monsters fighting each
other at the end and humans are helping
yeah in the middle of the [ __ ]
godzilla fight between two chinese
dragons that was pretty cool
um
but yeah i like i liked the movie also i
really like uh i like aquafina as well
she's always like funny and everything
oh yeah
yeah he's got chang she's got this kind
of tagalog sidekick who's this it's like
it's like his best friend
yeah but they were also kind of hitting
that there might be a romance that might
be building up or something with them
too i mean yeah it could be but i like
that they didn't shoehorn that in no
like they they were they seemed like
legitimately they were buddies and they
were just like had been buddies for 10
years and they were always hanging out
and [ __ ] with each other and singing
karaoke and whatnot yeah and she's
[ __ ] terrible taste in clothes
terrible yeah she was like super dorky
she was so super dorky and real [ __ ]
loud
yeah [ __ ] not sexy at all
funny but not sexy
but yeah so i liked i liked the dynamic
between the two of them because like i
said once they go to the other dimension
like aquafina goes too but um katie is
her character's name um but you know
aquafina goes too and like she kind of
has an arc too where she's
sort of like dorky and not good at
everything but then she kind of like
steps up and and whatnot but it's like i
just liked the you know the the
friendship between the two of them the
way that was kind of set up at the
beginning i liked the creatures um the
story was good the story was solid it
had a good
character arc you know gave you some
you know gave you a little background of
cha chi and uh
built him up some and then in the end by
the time this is kind of like not only
his origin story but his first mission
yeah at the end of it he's full on
change she at that at that time yeah
now
personally
did i enjoy this one more than shazam
no
shazam i liked it it was goofier and
more like a superhero fun superhero but
was this one good yeah yeah
it's in
the marvel motif
yeah the marvel has a certain motif it's
in that motif
but they they bent it to make it
make it chang she a chinese character it
is good it's good like i said i think
they struck a good balance between it
being a marvel movie
um but also being a stand-alone that you
don't have to be all up in like uh
marvel lore to enjoy it like i said
you'll obviously enjoy it more because
you'll catch all the little easter eggs
and stuff but you don't need to have
that it's like a very
it's a very like straightforward story
and it stands on its own
so i thought that was like so they
threaded that needle pretty pretty well
i think
um so yeah um we're actually going to
either tonight or tomorrow i want to see
uh malignant the james juan movie it's
like if we were kind of tired so we
might not go see it tonight so we might
see something else tonight but then we
might go see it tomorrow
um
but yeah so since so many of you guys
asked like it's because i didn't want to
i didn't want to do this at the
beginning because i didn't want people
complaining it's like why though you
were going to joke about movies yeah
right so i said well let's save it till
the end even though a couple people did
ask okay so
if you guys that were here friday night
um you know sorry
we uh he made a stir fry and like all
the oil smoke got in the um got in the
air and is like making my nose run but
um
so we met with the landlords on saturday
morning
and
we were like we were freaking out we
were sitting there going oh my god are
we gonna have to like buy this house
it's gonna be really expensive and it's
like are we gonna have to like move or
whatever uh so what they wanted
was they don't actually want to sell
this house
they want to move into this house right
they have like a [ __ ] ton of properties
and i guess this one is like the
location that they want or whatever
it is is that he's getting older and he
can't he does he can't go up downstairs
right so this is a flat house and they
like yeah so it's one story and this is
a nice neighborhood they want this house
man they want it it says man you got to
get the [ __ ] out
well they didn't say it like that no
that yeah that no seriously actually
they gave me a good deal yeah i because
i was kind of like only thinking there
was two possibilities but there was
actually a third possibility which is
which we didn't even think of which is
like actually the best possibility
possible yeah they broke so he's like
look man i don't normally do this but
you've been with me for 10 years never
been late on the rent the [ __ ] house
looks great [ __ ] i'll [ __ ] put you
in a better in a better house
they about the 10 miles of a flipped
road yeah two-story almost 50 they
basically said if you guys would let us
move into this house yeah for the same
rent yeah we will let you have this
other property that we own yeah um that
is a thousand square feet bigger than
this one yeah is two story yeah and is
five bedrooms and we have two months to
move and we have two months to move and
they said the house is empty right now
we're gonna go wednesday and see the
inside we went and saw the outside we've
seen photographs of the inside and we've
seen photographs of the inside still
painted in there they're
remodeling it so it's gonna be kind of
brand new and they basically said um
yeah so no one's living in it now um so
we'll give you the keys like if you if
you like the inside and you can just
start moving stuff in you can paint it
if you want to um you can pretty much do
whatever you want to bring to carpets
and everything um they're like so we
would like to have you as renters for
another 10 years or if you want to buy
the house that's fine too i got i got an
option to buy right so but um it's about
10 miles from here but it's not it's in
like a really nice neighborhood
it's got a it's on three quarters of an
acre yeah it's out near where i used to
work in the horse industry so i know the
area it's not it's only like i said it's
10 miles
it's uh
i'll show you guys pictures of it it's
it's right it's in usa it looks super
nice
and i mean there's like it's it's a lot
bigger than this house and like i said i
always wanted a house with a with two
stories there's not a lot of them the
house
on the out the exterior
it needs it needs to be painted again i
mean it's a newer house at least the
trim it's the same age as this house
it's 10 12 years old yeah something like
that but it needs trim paint
the color contrast it's the trim on it
is too light it's it's only a little bit
darker than the house itself which kind
of makes it just looks like a white box
i'm going to fix all that it also needs
landscaping stuff done we'll plant some
trees around it bushes and [ __ ] and
[ __ ] put some flowers it's got a big
backyard big backyard so we're going to
put some privacy hedges up and we're
also going to screen it it has a massive
back patio
but it's not screened in so we're going
to screen it in so the kitties can have
a catio yeah we're going to do that five
bedroom about three and a half baths
couple living rooms nice big kitchen
downstairs patio two-car garage the only
thing i didn't think i didn't like about
the house but hey bigger can't be
chooser you know it didn't have double
front doors it only has a single front
door so it's a big house with a single
front door on it that's all right it
needed to be double front doors i'm not
really bothered
whatever
i grew up in a trailer park it's like
somebody said hey for the same right
you're paying for this much smaller
house you can have this way bigger house
i'm gonna fix a house up i'd be like hey
yeah um so like i said it'll be a while
because we have like i said they have we
have two months to move and they said
you could just move [ __ ] like you can
start moving now we can start putting
your stuff in there because there's
nobody in there um so they're going to
give us the keys on wednesday they want
to move in here about two months from
well actually two months from now they
want us out yeah because they're going
to remodel the inside yeah and then
they're going to move in yeah but i'm
just going to slowly start transferring
[ __ ] over there over the next two months
yeah so i'm going to get a truck and
i'll take the big stuff like the beds
over there yeah it's going to be super
easy because and honestly you guys are
going to love it honestly like i said um
yeah the first thing my main priority is
i want to set up the office so we have
somewhere to stream from yeah studio and
office
got to get the internet going over there
i gotta um so i'm gonna like i gotta go
look at the layout and see which room
i'm gonna pick for
um
for the office
and kind of get it all and then like i
might paint it or something and like
we'll get some lights going in there
we'll get some cool [ __ ]
and uh it should be cool i think i'm i'm
like real excited about it you know it's
a good sweet deal it's good news oh yeah
it's very good news because it also
here's another thing else i got two
months to slowly move over there so
there's no rush
because yeah i like that because
honestly what i've i said it was gonna
be a move-in day there's gonna be
several moving months yeah just you know
[ __ ] that we don't need yes we'll just
pack it up and like throw it over and
like and it'll it's great
move we'll be over there it's nice too
because i'll be able to go in there we
can go in there and paint and [ __ ] like
that before there's any furniture in
there which will make it a lot easier
yeah um because that's kind of what i'm
the first thing that i'm going to do
storage stuff will go over there first
we'll do it later stuff we don't ever
use we'll go over there and to be honest
um all of the i don't really have i mean
other than the bed and like the tv and
[ __ ] like that we don't have a [ __ ] ton
of furniture yeah um and all of this
stuff in here like this desk is not
really mine it was your step-dad's um
and it's massive and i hate it
so i'm going to just either throw this
out or leave it um and my bookshelves
are falling apart so i'm going to get
some new ones so a lot of like my big
furniture i'm just going to throw it out
and get new [ __ ] yeah and what we do is
we'll just order it online and then add
and then have it delivered that's the
delivery there so then i don't have to
move anything because i was thinking
about it too because i was thinking i
hate this desk i mean i just used it i
mean it's nice because it's big and it's
old school that's a 20 year old but i've
always used it because it was free and
it was here yeah and it was here but
it's a [ __ ] to move yeah it's in like
three or four pieces it's in the wrong
colors it's it's brown it should be
black brown stuff yeah i hate brown
stuff no no so i just thought man i'm
just gonna leave this [ __ ] here yeah
throw it away and here's another thing
no money
yeah so we don't pay so we don't have to
like pay it'll just be
other than you know maybe a little bit
disruption yeah like when we're actually
going over there yeah um so that saves
me three grand in moving costs and
[ __ ] fees and all kinds of [ __ ] right
there like i said on pages i pay them on
them on the first of the month just the
same as usual same like same uh amount
and everything so i was like marvel and
lord love me so i don't need so i didn't
even like think of that being a
possibility no i mean neither that's
what i wanted but i was like oh my god
that's like the best possible outcome
because not only do i get to go through
all my [ __ ] get some new furniture and
like start over like and clean up this i
was like
i was sitting there like this and he
goes and he goes you sell this and he
goes no
but i want this house
i want to live here this is okay so i
gotta go he goes yeah but you're to go
here and he showed me i was like
where is this that's 10 miles up there
you can go yeah i was like yeah all
right he goes did the money to sam don't
worry he said same thing i don't do this
for anybody but you've been me 10 years
and you've never been late because and
plus we take care of his house without
the housing is good yeah so you can do
whatever you want you i want you for
another 10 years and i said what about
to buy and he goes yeah we talked
probably about 475. i was like okay
i think i'm talking down though you
probably could yeah well especially if
we run into it for several years yeah i
mean it's a nice neighborhood that
neighborhood it's not enclosed but it's
all nice houses yeah it's not true it's
not gated but it's out in like where all
the horse farms and stuff are but it's
like but the neighborhood looks
comparable to this it was a good sign i
went around the side man saw a big old
pile of five five six and nine
millimeter brass on the side of that
thing this [ __ ] over here was
shooting out here
probably before the rest of those houses
were built
yeah because this house i mean it's it's
a neighborhood it's a normal
neighborhood but this house has a lot a
lot more room around it than the other
ones do yeah there's room out there to
put a big you can put a pool if you want
to put a swimming pool out there you
could put there's plenty of room rock
rock paths rock gardens and i'm gonna
put trees and [ __ ]
because man it's just sitting there it
does have
it does have hedges and [ __ ] in the
front but it's just the landscaping is
basic it needs good landscaping i look
around at the neighbors and some of
those neighbors man they're how they're
[ __ ] like mansions they're the same
size
but i noticed that my landlord what he
did he owned 13 of these things and he
would go on a block and buy go into a
good neighborhood and buy the ugliest
house on that in that damn block or the
plainest the plainest one and he'd
probably got a good deal on it and he
was planning on flipping them
but
it's the same house as everybody else
has pretty much it's just that it didn't
have all the deluxe [ __ ]
[ __ ] it doesn't have all the molding and
yeah it doesn't have all that stuff on
it which
if i bought it i'd probably put all that
on it some of that could be fixed just
with paint and landscaping
yeah to be honest i think that's kind of
like and like i said screening in the
patio yeah um because and also uh lawn
lighting the lighting that shines up
inside the trees up on the side of the
house you know there's nice little
accent lighting that everybody else has
it goes down driveways and everything
that would change it a lot too
um yeah so yeah um where did i just see
that khan said you can uh design your
new studio for the show yeah that's
exactly what i'm gonna do and like i
said i'm not taking any of the streaming
[ __ ] over there until like the last
minute
um i'm gonna set all you know and and
most of this [ __ ] i can leave some of
this [ __ ] in the background but some of
the [ __ ] i might just slowly like pack
up and stuff and i can put everything
like exactly the way i want it before we
start streaming from there and it's 50
to 60 percent bigger the ha the rooms
are all bigger yeah the top floor has
got a spiral staircase that goes up that
ends up in a landing with ledges that
look down into the living rooms and its
rooms and
the hallway goes in a circle around a
bunch of rooms
and some of the rooms kind of can see
into one another just well it just has
it has like a big lounge big lounge that
just has arches so we're going to bar up
in there we're going to turn that into
like a bar snack type area so i'm going
to put like a little coffee pot and a
little mini fridge and [ __ ] so we don't
have to go downstairs probably have that
all set up around
like a support studio support area for
the studio
yeah that's where we can get up make a
drink and make coffee while we're doing
where we're working and doing the studio
maybe make that part of the studio we'll
just see how the layout is yeah because
i don't want to really walk through it
yet just seen pictures we've seen the
outside and we've seen the pictures but
i'm not sure like i can sort of see how
it's laid out but i want to see like
which one
we want to use for the office because
there's several rooms upstairs and they
all seem pretty big i'll shoot some
videos when i go down there maybe
wednesday i'll probably be down there or
sometime after that and i'll shoot some
videos and maybe we'll post it while
it's empty so you guys can see where
yeah louis said 475 is a good price it
is for um for that area and for uh that
house is um 3 500 square feet yeah uh
this house i think is 2400. in
california and that one is fi like i
said that one's five bedrooms three and
a half baths this one's a four or three
if that was in california it'd probably
be two and a half million probably it's
big big yeah
it's nice
but yeah so i'm i'm super
i'm super jacked so like i said like the
next couple months
i'm gonna go through all my [ __ ] i'm
gonna throw out a bunch of stuff
actually because i've been waiting for
an excuse to do that yeah and i just i
already ordered some moving boxes get
rid of some of the dead wood i already
like
looking at some paint colors i'm already
like doing all kind of [ __ ] i'm going to
go wednesday and like measure the
windows and [ __ ] like that for curtains
and all that kind of crap i'm gonna get
i got already picked out some new new
desk all right you know and then i want
to get it to where i don't i could it's
not a big deal for me to rent these reds
i can rent a truck for like 20 a day
like a u-haul type truck some of the
smaller ones
and enterprise will do a van or at least
they did last when i moved and that was
a while back i just got to be able to it
was pretty cheap
i could i could ride the motorcycles
there if you go with me and you can
drive me back yeah it's mostly the beds
that's really i mean most of our other
furniture is not that large beds and
chairs and [ __ ] there's a couple there's
like a couple sofas but they're not that
heavy
they're not heavy it's just big and we
have like a bunch of little chairs and
stuff but they're super light yeah like
i got cheap chairs on purpose because i
knew pookie's going to tear them up and
she did
[Laughter]
little 50 chairs she just she goes every
single day when she walks past those
chairs she puts her little things on and
stretches
yeah and as much as you yell at her
she's just like what like what so uh
yeah
scratching posts yeah thank you for all
these scratching posts yeah
mommy and daddy
uh yeah so
hopefully that's uh good news for we
were very excited about it i was like
man that's that turned out like way
better than uh yeah see if you need to
know what you said you'd end up worried
about anything well louie said in
california it'd be like 1.5 million easy
tom especially in socal
yeah
how many how many square feet was it
it's two stories it's about it's almost
3 500 square feet 3 500 square feet and
it's on three quarters of an acre yeah
and it has two-car garage uh upstairs uh
upstairs downstairs um big kitchens
it's like i said it's fine stainless
steel five bedroom three and a half bath
all stainless steel kitchen the whole uh
the whole first story is tile yeah and
then the upstairs is carpeted right it's
nice nice yeah um
it's just the outside man i need to
[ __ ] paint that trim the right color
and like i said it wouldn't take much
all you need to do
the main problem is just got ladders and
[ __ ] it's just that the trim and the
actual house are almost the same shade
so it just looks like so all you need to
do is like um paint the trim darker yeah
and it would like really pop out and go
to home depot and like buy some of those
stone gargoyle [ __ ] things like stick
them on there it'll be fine it'll look
good and like like i said we need some
bushes in the backyard like
down the side like a price down the side
of that house it needs a
like a like a
a raised
i don't talk to a little swole because
he does that [ __ ] for a living i also
know the guy who does landscaping it
needs to be like a raised flower bed
about six foot deep i'm going all the
way down the side of that house with
trees in it and [ __ ] little round
bushes and stuff a tree that'll go up
almost to the lake
oh that's right i forgot that little
swole does yeah all that kind of stuff
oh [ __ ] need some bushes that can almost
be as high as the damage
to hide the side of that house because
that's the side the sun comes up on and
you'll lose you it'll bake the side of
that and i was going to say if we needed
any electricianship my brother's an
electrician okay so you know just
putting that out there yeah i don't know
if we'll need anything along that line
but if we do i can just call him and go
hey i'll pay you to come in like you can
try the hell over here i hate doing
landscaping [ __ ] i'd rather pay somebody
do they uh i would as well well and
honestly too their equipment you gotta
eat trucks and [ __ ] well the the
landlord didn't they also say that um
that the lawn crew
was included in the rent just like it is
here yeah but they don't do landscaping
no i know no i know that but i'm just
saying that you know that's why it comes
along that's why we got rid of like
their our lawn mowers and all that kind
of [ __ ]
it just takes up room
for people easier to just hire these
dudes they show up and get done 10
minutes and get they get the [ __ ] out
yeah there's like eight of them
all from central america jump up smiling
little bitty [ __ ] smiling yeah
thank you
now it's like i said it's a it's a big
neighborhood but it's not gated like it
has a big sign and everything but it's
not gated it did there's no hoa is there
nope oh okay so that's nope
so you can do what you want
that's good yeah that was kind of one of
one thing here that had no [ __ ]
a little bit of pain how high your grass
is and [ __ ] what color and is there
any stains in the damn driveway there
they're painted yeah we had to get the
driveway and you could climb it pressure
washed a couple gonna find us yeah
but yeah so there's no hoa at the new
place so that's another good thing
all right so
uh is that all we had to
talk about today
i'm just i don't know why i'm like so i
think it was all the
all the smoke and then this is three
quarters of an acre that's that's gonna
be two million depending on the city
yeah
yeah i was like actually i was really um
saying yeah next thing you know a cenote
appears in your backyard yeah really
yeah
actually i mean it's kind of it's a big
big backyard that if you go up back and
you go farther enough there's just
another house there and i don't like
that direct [ __ ] eye contact between
the two just an empty space
i'm gonna put
stone flag stones and [ __ ] down in there
and make like a [ __ ] garden with
bushes and [ __ ]
bushes and [ __ ] bushes and [ __ ] doesn't
that sound good bushes looks and
honestly like bushes like privacy hedges
look better looking better than fences
yeah i put some privacy ahead which
isn't [ __ ] there's trees there's
landscaping in the front like near the
front door yeah but like in the back not
so much there's some there's some trees
in the back but there it's just like
open yeah just get a post hole digger
and start [ __ ] dig digging and put
put buy some bushes and put them in
there that's not a big deal and it's
like the neighborhood is like right
across the street from like a big huge
horse farm yeah so
the only thing was that well it's now
you used to like i said used to work
down there because you worked in the
horse business so you used to work down
there like ten
eleven twelve years ago yeah yeah i
still know people there you might yeah
and um
he said when he worked back there back
then uh there was like nothing out there
it was like really but now it's just
like um maybe like less than a mile up
the road they just built a big thing
with like a publix grocery store
sushi restaurant a chinese restaurant an
ice cream shop a haircutting place when
i lived there there was a liquor store
there's so there's like a big shopping
mall there now which is good because i
don't want to be out in the middle of
nowhere only thing there's an amc in
that area only thing that sucks is that
sam's
is that the same sam's that we go to now
is the sams that serves that area and
it's kind of far but and i still got to
drive all the way down here to pick up
my [ __ ] test
oh yeah that's right i can't have them
ship it to my house but it probably
delays it a couple days that's true
but it's only what 20 uh
it would be only a 15 mile ride
yeah it's not far like i said we drove
there yesterday to look at the outside
because we have the keys yet and i was
like okay well that's not that far
that's near that mexican that's near
that that's near that mexican store
where i used to have to ride out
remember to go get my house that's right
to go get your hot sauce now it's only
three miles away
that's right because i knew we had been
out there before because i've been to
that mexican store because we ate in
that restaurant there louie and khan
would love that place man it's like
going to mexico they got the whole
mexico store there all the mexican stuff
you can get mexican coca-cola uh they're
making tortillas in there they got a
restaurant in there and half of it's a
restaurant and it's a butcher shop and
it's good and they they speak english in
there the staff but nobody else in there
does everybody else is from uh mexico or
central america
it's a big grocery store i'm surprised
yeah but they have they would have iwaka
cheese and all that they have they have
everything there
uh to make uh mexican cuisine
i have to take i have to take some video
up to show them they probably trip out
on that yeah next time we're up there
yeah might as well because you know
that's like i said it's a cool place
yeah and i and i thought because i've
been out there before and i knew when we
were driving out there so i'm like yeah
this kind of looks familiar that must
have been when we went to that store
earlier yeah you go in there it's all
decorated in [ __ ] mexican colors and
[ __ ] you know the red red white and good
green
looking banners going everywhere and you
know and they're [ __ ]
mexican music and the restaurant is just
like fast food you go up to the went and
go up to the window and they've got like
a
grill back there in the griddle and
just you know they're good
there is always same things on the menu
but those have specials
you know they're just gonna be a bunch
of it's mostly the long crew guys yeah
long crew guys in the in the farm
workers yeah because it's like going in
there
to eat to eat and buy supplies
yeah it's pretty cool it's pretty cool
so like i said we're really excited
about it like i said i'm already i'm
already like
picking out furniture and
paint colors and or i already ordered a
[ __ ] ton of boxes i'm gonna start
packing all my [ __ ] up yeah
i'm excited and you can reuse those
boxes too well yeah for those yeah
yeah i just got some from like amazon
like a big pack of them
all right
so i guess that'll do it for today
um so we'll be back tomorrow have a good
rest of your weekend everybody all right
constant i'm gonna he's gonna send me a
video of something i need to order from
there called machete it's a [ __ ] meal
oh okay all right
are we sure that's something that's good
or is it something or is it somebody
just going hey eat this yeah
you know what i mean yeah so we'll be
back tomorrow at 3 p.m with another
movie review and
whatever else we are gonna jabber about
uh thanks for dropping by everybody and
we'll see you guys tomorrow
bye